[Music]
hey here we are
yet again yeah and pokey trying to climb
[ __ ] pull out the side of the chair
try to pull outside of the chair leave
it alone poke
go play with some toys she's like play
attach it to me yeah hey attach it all
right so uh we're doing the second part
of the uh sicario thing uh
day of the soldado that's where that's
that's when you're it's spanglish parts
spanish and part english
but uh
good movie um same writer
uh same
uh
same cast
well more or less it had like some of
the same people yeah most the same
people didn't have the girl of course
she couldn't work with them anymore
but um
just
got the damn assassin and
got the
brolins in it he's looking saucy as [ __ ]
big ol arms
i know his game
he's on he's on the juice
but hey man he's [ __ ] that's what
that's what you'd be doing you know
[ __ ] if that's what you did for a
living you'd be on a [ __ ] juice
um
and it's just another good movie not
quite as artistic as the first one
more um
more action oriented i would think
uh but still satisfying satisfying
movement i liked the movie i liked it i
liked it i did as well i don't know if
i'd go so far say i like it better than
the first one because the first one was
kind of like a masterpiece and i will
say that this one is you know it
obviously didn't have the same director
uh denis villeneuve and it didn't have
the same cinematographer roger deakins
it's so good yeah but it's still like
really really good um
i liked that the story i you know what
though i think i preferred
the story in this one though yeah it was
more fun i think not really fun yeah not
fun i don't think that's the word but um
more direct more um
but also like an action but like more
complex at the same time too like with
all kind of yeah
double crosses and false flags
start a drug war
basically between all the cartels that
was that was their secret mission
and they end up almost starting to down
war with mexico itself because they have
to [ __ ] attack the mexican army
turned on them when they were in a
convoy and they killed a bunch of them
and that ended up on the news and the
president got pissed the u.s president
got pissed
um
and then uh
del toro's in it he's like he he has a
huge role in it yeah i like that they
expanded his role in this one because
it's mostly i don't know if i'd say it
was mostly about him but he's in it i
mean he's kind of the main case he's the
main dude yeah brolin also yeah
um
they're just
two different characters with different
story arcs
it's kind of like
gray and black
you know what i mean the brolin's his
[ __ ] is just he's just gray
del toro is just kind of black
you know
he's the creature of evil
but he still has a moral center though
like which is demonstrated
at the end of this movie here's here's
the thing
what are you doing folks what you're
doing pope
that keep hearing
conventional morality these people live
in a world of good versus evil
in in this game and
in combat arms it's not a world of good
versus evil that you live in you live in
a world of evil versus evil
but what makes you better than the other
evil is that you're using evil to reduce
the sum total of evil for the benefit of
mankind
so it's like a personal sacrifice
to better the world that is the idea
because you can't reason with these
[ __ ] you got to kill them
and sometimes sending messages and doing
things that are [ __ ] terrible
can
psychologically attract the
the enemy to break them down
uh you know there's a bunch of [ __ ]
games that you can do and they're doing
it in this movie so i like the fact that
they discuss all this
and uh but del toro
yeah
he's evil evil versus evil but he's
trying to benefit mankind yeah all right
and the way it ends you're not sure what
happened
i think he was going to recruit the kid
and i think he was going to recruit that
kid because i think he suspected that
the kid shot him in the mouth
to fake
to to maybe let him live maybe you
better he killed the kid it's left yeah
it's left ambiguous well like i said
they they're working on a third one as
far as i'm aware so they do kind of set
up
like a third
installment yeah
and we're not really sure where it's
going it could have gone either way i
kind of thought
i mean and hopefully everybody's seen
the movie because it's hard to talk
about it without like spoiling it but
you know what i mean so i kind of
thought at first i was kind of like oh
he's probably gonna kill the kid but
then he's like hey thanks for shooting
me in the face [ __ ] but um
but then i was kind of like well
like you said he's probably gonna
recruit him because he does say like oh
so you want to be a sicario yeah and
then it's time to talk about your future
and i was like yeah whether or not you
have one or not but there was that kind
of thing so
and i don't know and i kind of feel like
what i was saying when uh when i said
that he had a moral center it was
because
i mean he was supposed to
they were supposed to kill that little
girl yeah i mean she wanted a little
girl she was 16. but they were supposed
to kill her like after everything went
sideways
because uh you know
[ __ ] i kind of made a joke like halfway
between
like halfway in the movie when you know
[ __ ] kind of just started going like
wildly pear shaped and i'm sitting there
going and i was like
imagining i was josh brolin's character
being like man why can't our secret
black ops ever go smoothly it always has
to always somebody always has to [ __ ] us
over and it's just kind of always they
always get [ __ ] over in the end yeah
now
when i was talking about the first
sicario movie
i mentioned that there's a guy that i
follow online i've talked to him his
name is larry vickers he's a pretty
famous uh ex-delta agent
and uh he's real good dude makes good
videos [ __ ] tests machine guns out
[ __ ] does historical reviews but he
reviewed
the first sicario movie and the one
character the guy with the glasses
um
larry believes that he was modeled after
this guy all right it was uh sergeant
major
mike vining
[ __ ]
just touching this thing i lose my
[ __ ] pictures he does some [ __ ]
that's him right there
and the white shirt with the glasses he
was one of norman schwarzkopf's
bodyguards but he was around since the
vietnam era he did a bunch of [ __ ] but
he was a
delta and did all kinds of spooky [ __ ]
and he just wore those damn
birth control glasses
and um
they say he was just a [ __ ] fantastic
on the job and just
supreme marksman
and just everybody liked him
but that's probably who he was modeled
after
because
back during the uh first gulf war there
were a lot of pictures of [ __ ] storm
and norman and video on cnn storm and
norman walking around and he'd be out
there in front of storm and norman all
the time it's us every time you saw a
storm of norman you'd see him out there
with the [ __ ]
suppressed carbines and [ __ ] like that
you're like who's that dude
him so i think the character that they
used in sicario was modeled after that
guy
well so so does larry larry thinks that
too
even though it's like i said that guy
doesn't really have any doesn't have i
think he has a slightly larger role in
this one
but he doesn't really have that big of a
role like i said it's definitely a
supporting character it's a supporting
character yeah but
yeah so
if you don't know like okay so this
movie i kind of like this because
it's not
yeah it's a sequel i guess
but you could watch it as a standalone
like you don't have to see them both i
guess it helps if you do
but
i mean it's it's its own story you know
what i'm saying it's not necessarily a
continuation of the first mission i mean
other than like all of the
characters like
having the characters reappear and stuff
and that's probably
you know helpful to watch the first one
but you don't really have to have seen
the first one to watch this one you can
follow it without that both of them were
standalones that's what i'm saying so
it's almost kind of like it's set in the
same universe with some of the same
characters but it's just like a
different mission i have a feeling uh
the first movie the car it was i think
that was just going to be a standalone i
don't think i don't think there was
going to be a sequel
because it didn't even set up for a
sequel yeah
really yeah the way it was written and
the way it ends it was very
self-contained so i guess just in case
they didn't have a sequel it would be
like just apocalypse now there'd just be
one
you know it was good i really did yeah i
kind of wonder like when they started
talking maybe because the first one was
i don't know though i feel like a lot of
movies particularly ones that aren't
parts of big action franchises or
anything like that even if it's really
successful which the first sicario was
and you know even though it got a lot of
oscar nominations and stuff like that
it's like a movie like that doesn't
usually get a sequel this is not usually
sicario isn't usually the kind of movie
that they would normally do a sequel for
so
i don't know maybe it was just the
writer
taylor sheridan and he was just kind of
like oh i i like that you know benicio
del toro character alejandro and he's
like and i want to do something else
with that guy so maybe he just went
there and said hey let's do another
standalone movie but with the same
characters and it'll kind of be like a
sequel
i don't know i don't know how that came
about but it's the same writer like i
said
so
this one
i don't know like i said i kind of liked
emily blunt in the first one
but i liked that this one
was kind of the same thing but it was
also kind of like a different thing like
it didn't really have a character like
her this was basically just following
you didn't really have any good guys in
this i mean everyone was
varying shades of like you said from
gray to black everywhere there's no like
good guys in this whereas emily blunt
was set up very much as like the good
guy
um you know what i mean she was kind of
the only one that was still like
thinking like trying to follow the laws
and everything like that whereas nobody
else was this one like nobody's trying
to follow laws at all and little girl
wasn't good
that's what i'm saying like everybody in
this so it's pretty grim yeah but
i don't know like it's i don't know if
i'd call it like entertaining
necessarily like it is entertaining but
it is also like really really grim but
all of the characters even though
they're all differing shades of bad guys
are all like really interesting yeah so
the deaf guy was good
that's right the deaf the deaf guy from
like two scenes yeah he was like the
only good guy
and i'm sure well and i'm sure like some
of the some of the poor like immigrants
like on the bus and everything like that
they they seemed like all nice people
and everything like that the deaf guy
was mystified these guys just coming out
of the damn desert with this little girl
and he's like that's that girl that's
missing in it one of his kidnapped you
know and it was good that was a really
good scene they were like hi you know
and they were like how do you as a
soldier you know how do you know about
sign language which is ridiculous you
know [ __ ] you guys know me [ __ ]
wesley my cousin's death i know sign
i grew up with son
so yeah you never can't tell anybody so
you know soldiers have a [ __ ] wide
variety of backgrounds they're not
monolithic but i just thought that was
funny dialogue i guess a person would
think that
well i mean del toro wouldn't know sign
language but i would kind of think if
you were a deaf person you would
probably just assume that most people
wouldn't know right you know what i mean
so any just any random rando that like
wanders up on your property you're just
going to assume they don't know silence
well that was the girl though so that
was the girl that was the girl that said
that that's true how do you know about
sign language when she was a little kid
though but she yeah she was a teenager
and she had grown up in a really like uh
privileged sheltered environment yeah
she was a narcos
daughter narcos yeah she was like a
narco princess she had her own 30 room
mansion with cars and [ __ ] like that
yeah that was one of the funny lines
like that guy was like i wish i was a
teenager yeah that was the guy that
i modeled
after sergeant major fanning he was like
[ __ ] i wish i was a teenage girl
well not every teenage girl i guess
they're in a 30 room mansion i certainly
didn't get one yeah but yeah so but yeah
this kind of shows like how [ __ ] up
um
all of these kind of operations are and
how easy it is for everything to go
drastically awry right i mean
even at the beginning where you have
supposedly
uh you know members of isis coming in
through the mexican border and like
blowing up people in kansas city and so
this
kind of stems like the guy um who's who
is from the deep department of defense
or if it's like the guy that matthew
modine is playing
and they're basically like okay well we
want to send a message or like punish
the mexican cartels but they seem to be
all like peaceful at the moment so let's
[ __ ] them up let's go in there and stage
like a bunch of
false flag operations to get them to
fight each other so they basically go in
there they assassinate one high up guy
like the lawyer i think for like for the
matamoros uh cartel like they go and
assassinate him and then they say that
it's the other cartel that did it and
then they go and
kidnap uh the daughter the 16 year old
daughter of uh what was his name carlos
reyes who i think who was the guy that
uh
that told the people to kill alejandro's
family
right so that's why they brought him
like back on this mission so yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] up so now they have this
teenage girl in custody and they're
trying to make her think that the
matamoros cartel
abducted her yeah so they put her in the
safe house and then they
like have
then they're just kind of like have all
these other people come in and like hi
we're like the americans and we're here
to save you even though it's the same
people that took her
so
yeah and so she's just kind of like
wagged around with them and eventually
it gets to a point where
they uh the mexican army the mexican
police and [ __ ] like that like turn on
the
you know the the american operation
and at that point like they end up
shooting like a whole bunch of mexican
cops
and then the mexican government has a
[ __ ] freak out about it and they're
like oh the little girl saw all of that
so now she's got to be eliminated and
you know alejandra has to be eliminated
and there's this whole thing and then
there's that other subplot with like the
kid like the teenage boy that's kind of
being groomed into
uh
you know helping like
groomed into one of the cartels
essentially like helping like smuggle
people across the border and [ __ ] like
that because they find out later on
that the whole isis people like coming
through the mexican border that didn't
even happen like they just like the
cartels just faked that
so even like the information that they
were acting on like at the very start
like was not true yeah that's right
so was what was the del toro guy he was
on the run after that because they
wanted to kill him right they were going
to kill him well and he must be on a run
yeah so that was well because josh
brolin yeah
called him he at least gave him the
thing where he warned him and he's like
look you know you and the girl like we
gotta rub you out uh you know that's
what we're supposed to do now that's
right and uh so he so he basically just
said good luck yeah um well you know
everybody did recruit that kid because
he would have needed him that's what i'm
saying yeah but see
now we don't know like did everybody
think he was dead because yeah they
probably no they probably just thought
he was on the run
well because well because josh brolin
like saw
uh you saw him get shot yeah because
remember they were up in the helicopter
and he was like he's like oh i'm glad we
didn't have to do that because they were
supposed to kill him but that was his
friend yeah they didn't see him after
that so they didn't know he survived the
bullet right that's right right they
think he's dead right which probably is
the best scenario because yeah i i was
thinking that they saw him afterwards no
no they didn't they didn't really bring
that up because yeah they they saw him
die like i said they saw him just laying
there in the quarry or whatever with
that other teenager that they shot he
didn't get into the green truck until
after the [ __ ] helicopters left right
yeah right that's what i'm saying so
they don't know so they think he's dead
that's right which like i said is
probably good for him yeah because but
then like at the end when they jump
ahead
they jump ahead a year
it's not it's good for him they think
he's that they think he's dead but it's
not over the third one's coming out so
you know he's gonna be in it
he's probably gonna have to clear his
name and get himself cleared
and get himself off the hit list that's
what's gonna happen there yeah and then
probably the only way to do that is get
dirt on somebody
yeah i'm interested to see because i
mean i think he's the best character i
mean josh brolin is great in this too
yeah like i liked him because he was i
think danny rowling said something about
it uh you know when he got his arm all
[ __ ] up like did he get shot or
stabbed i can't remember but he got like
his arm got all [ __ ] up and they were
like you got shot during the uh
you got shot during the helicopter scene
dudes at the end right
well this was kind of more like halfway
through the movie where they kind of
like [ __ ] up his arm so much [ __ ]
happened i'd have to watch him i had to
watch it again and he was back at the
thing like kind of trying to put some
stuff over it and they said and they
said well that's going to need stitches
and he said oh well good luck for me
like you know i'll still need stitches
tomorrow yeah and then like uh what's
her name comes in and says about it he's
like [ __ ] mondays you know what i
mean which i thought was like super
funny but yeah he's just like
he's a funny character but like i said i
kind of like too that even though
josh brolin's character and benicio del
toro's character are uh you know matt
and alejandra or their characters names
but even though obviously they're not
good guys and they do all kind of
terrible things um
they both had
you know they both couldn't go all the
way with it you know what i'm saying
because when you get to then like
benicio del toro he you know he
basically like took off with that little
girl and then they said hey we're gonna
kill you and he's like yeah i can't let
that happen and he just like took off
with her
and then it turned out too that josh
brolin was supposed to kill the little
girl and he couldn't do it either yeah
and he's like so he's gonna get in
trouble because
he was supposed to wipe her he was
supposed to like eliminate her because
she saw yeah all of the [ __ ] were
because they were trying to cover up the
whole thing where they killed all the
mexican cops because the government was
pissed um they knew that the little girl
was there and saw the whole thing so
they're like yeah you need to get rid of
her he's going to figure out some way to
flip all that around
save everybody's skins that's what'll
happen
yeah i can't now i'm kind of curious if
they do do a third one like are they
going to carry on i imagine they're
going to carry on maybe from like the
repercussions from this because like i
said i'm sure josh brolin's character is
going to get in trouble
for
saving that girl when he was supposed to
you know get rid of her he was supposed
to kill her but he couldn't do it i
don't know how old [ __ ] josh brolin
is but he was looking good in this
[ __ ] his arms and [ __ ] he was [ __ ]
training and stuff and he doesn't he
doesn't look
he doesn't look like he did a
bodybuilding routine he just looked like
he did a performance routine he he was
[ __ ] rejuvenated he looked [ __ ]
strong
which you know i like it when they look
like that because then you can buy it
what they're doing if guy doesn't look
he looked strong enough to do what he
was doing you know i liked it
yeah
yeah well you guys that's like i can't
say no no i just thought you were going
to say something else i never know when
you're done talking
does like it when they look the part he
looks the part in it
and this movie isn't that old it only
came out 2018 so it's only
four years old yeah so there's that so i
don't know what he looks like nowadays
i'm so well he's in [ __ ] all the time he
was in the marvel movies wasn't he well
year was this him 2018 2018 okay so he's
still about like that so it was three
years it was three years after the first
one yeah that they that they made this
one
um you know it's kind of a shame like i
said they didn't have the same
cinematographer although the
cinematography on this is nice it's not
as beautiful as the first one but
um and it's kind of sad too that the guy
that did the score of the original one
he died
um so they got like the guy that worked
with him i think like on the score in
the first one so the score on this one
is similar you know so it's kind of the
same style which i liked um and it's
interesting too how both of these movies
had european directors you know denis
villeneuve the first one was is french
obviously and the director of this one
was italian and interestingly i don't
know he might have made other movies but
the director of this has mostly just
done italian tv
which i thought was kind of well you see
he did a good job i really liked
the action sequences in this one i think
they were really like
well staged because they weren't
i don't even know if i'd call them so
much action sequences because they were
filmed like the way they were shot was
like really realistic rather than like
trying to be glamorous or cool or
anything like that they were trying to
like put you in the situation there was
a lot of practical effects and there was
a lot of practical effect yeah some some
of this stuff like especially the stuff
like the people blowing up at the
beginning and like all the people
getting shot and stuff were like real
very visceral as you it just kind of
felt like you were really there it was a
good scene where uh
del toro is in a damn vehicle and some
bad guys this is towards the end he's
already [ __ ] up he's all shot up he's
been shot through the mouth and
everything to the teeth and
um his face is all swelling up and they
uh came up behind him and got up next to
him and shot at him and he [ __ ]
tossed a grenade with his left hand hard
to do all right those things are [ __ ]
heavy and
they don't throw that well he [ __ ]
tossed it and it goes in there and they
slow down [ __ ] trying to get the
grenade out and it goes off boom and it
was a good
practical effect um
it was definitely an explosion
um unfortunately they always get the
explosions wrong um
they'll use explosions that are
red like with flames
because it's easier i guess and it looks
better on films
it's not what a grenade actually looks
like when it goes off it looks like a
flash cube
and then a white shock wave around and
it just [ __ ] blows it blows
everything off of it you see [ __ ]
pieces of clothing [ __ ] fluttering
down like [ __ ]
feathers coming off a [ __ ] bird and
stuff you know high explosive
bad [ __ ] and if it's in closed area
[ __ ] just like in a car just blows
every [ __ ] window out of it crumpled
the car up
but it still looked good even though i
could tell that wasn't a high explosive
it was it still looked good it looked
like it it really did blow up
yeah it just you know but it looked like
a gasoline explosion but it looked good
it wasn't too big people think that
those things go off big like my problem
with predator those explosions are too
big
yeah [ __ ] grenade goes off [ __ ]
like a glorified firework but it's
intense it'll [ __ ] kill you
especially like i said in an enclosed
area
it's high explosive it's the shock waves
like getting hit with a [ __ ] bat
and it literally blows pieces of
clothing off of you
but yeah i did like that particular
explosion inside the car i think was
really well good it didn't look like it
might have been cgi but it didn't look
like it yeah and like you said i think
the real explosion the reason that they
use explosions like that i think like it
just like you said on film it does look
better when it's kind of like orange and
red and everything because that's what
most people's idea yeah of an explosion
is if you were to actually film a
grenade going off in that situation in a
car it would look like a
a flash cube it would be look kind of
disappointing but then you'd see a big
white puff
you know and [ __ ] slide
you know you can see you know war
footage and of you know things [ __ ] h
e going off but it just doesn't look
very it doesn't look good yeah it's not
a cinematic it's not a cinnamon so
that's why yeah i mean the actual
explosion the actual explosive in there
is a little bit bigger than a ping-pong
ball there's not much in it
it's enough though yeah
but yeah i really i mean i really just
did like the i don't know they're just
the kind of the grounded reality of it
they really didn't make it look like
i don't know like not glamorous
necessarily but they didn't they didn't
overdo it they didn't make it look like
an action film right in an action film
it's kind of you can tell there's a
certain edit to it to
they wanted to make it look more like
war footage
yeah that's kind of more what it looked
like like i said if you were like
embedded with yeah you know it kind of
looked like that yeah
[ __ ] shooting people and [ __ ]
never looks as cool in real life as it
does in the movies in the movies well
nothing at all
just if you guys want to see what it
looks like what it looks like really
looks like there's a [ __ ] youtube
channel called police activity and it's
all the damn body cameras
off the cops and all the shootings and
you see like
you almost laugh because it's so stupid
dude doing something oh and it falls you
know
and you know like why do you do that
what was the plan there you know what i
mean [ __ ] it just dudes are stupid
you know
why would you chase the dudes are stupid
dudes are stupid you know what i mean
okay
and it has a pocket knife out like that
and i'll [ __ ] charge [ __ ] five
cops they're all [ __ ] paired with
ar-15s that's some suicide they just
[ __ ] kill you right yeah yeah yeah i
mean i would think dumb
dumb they want to die but i guess
they're like too cowardly to do it
themselves i guess so they're just like
well i'm gonna make cops shoot me well
they're responding to something that the
dude did you know i mean [ __ ]
stealing [ __ ] from a store or something
and then they just [ __ ] it i'm gonna die
dumb dumb but it doesn't look very uh
action-packed and you can see real um
gunfights they don't really look that
action-packed when you look at security
camera or or
you know body camera footage or even gun
camera footage you know from it looks
like slow motion compared to what it
would look like in the movies
a lot of the times um
one of the most action-packed gun fights
i ever saw was security camera of two
mexican cartels
shooting it out in front of a damn store
and it involves a car
drive drives up it's like a vehicle
ambush and about six guys in there open
up on them and they kill some of the
guys [ __ ] instantly and then other
guys start pouring out returning fire
and they're shooting at each other from
across the street and then the car comes
back and it went on for a long time and
dudes are jumping out this door is what
to see watch the gun fight and [ __ ]
bullets are [ __ ] ricocheting and
impacting all around the door frame
you're like dude get back in but little
fat boy wants to see the gunfight and
[ __ ] and he's like 40 wants to watch the
gut down and he's got his [ __ ]
mexican cowboy hat on yeah i see the
whole [ __ ] i don't need to see the guy
fight i'm good yeah it's looking good
oh you're doing good you're doing good
you know it was wild
yeah [ __ ] bee's nest is in there he
knows the exact gunfight we're talking
about he showed it to me
yeah yeah but like you said when you see
real footage and stuff like that it's
not usually
it doesn't usually look like it doesn't
look that good well because like i said
the whole thing about a movie experience
as you're supposed to like it's supposed
to look cinematic you know what i mean
so it's obviously going to look like way
like larger than life and like way
cooler than [ __ ] looks in real life yeah
sometimes you see like the real [ __ ] and
you're like
yeah dudes getting gacked over really
[ __ ] nothing important and [ __ ] you
know and just dumb luck
and like why are you doing this you know
why resist you know they if they arrest
you you're only gonna be in there for a
couple weeks you know i don't understand
what why are you resisting you know well
if they had that kind of force they they
probably wouldn't have they would have
been doing it with their edition
in the first place right uh you know so
there's probably that if they if they
had enough kind of like yeah
chill to like
realize that
but yeah um so i don't know so did you
like this one better than the first one
or
i don't know if i can say that like
they're different they're different like
they're kind of the same but you can
tell it's the same writer
but
i think they're different enough that
they're just both good on their own
you know the first one is kind of like
uh
a drug war special operations
masterpiece
i think i think what you came up was
good that it was kind of like apocalypse
now like a more modern version well i
didn't come up with that i just read it
you read it though but you came up with
it so you told me about it and i'll give
you the credit okay thank you
so kind of like apocalypse now the
second one
you can tell it's the same
writers you could tell it's it's real
close but it's just a different mission
and more stuff happens in it it's good
it's kind of a more complicated story
than the first one i feel like the
second one's almost kind of like a damn
godfather movie with some more action in
it yeah although i would hesitate to
call either one of them an action movie
no
because that's not really their primary
focus like there are like some good
action sequences in it but that's not
really the whole point of the movie well
i don't know kind of like the way i
remembered scarface i haven't seen
scarface in a long time but man we
should re-watch that i haven't seen that
in a long time in a long time but it's
just kind of a it's just a narco movie
with some special operations guys and
one of the things that i liked about is
that just showed
deception you know how these
special opera how these [ __ ] special
units will just
deceive
their enemies
by you know
attacking them in the name of [ __ ]
you know like they'll attack a drug
cartel and claim to be another cartel to
get yeah the whole thing that they were
like
yeah just it's like hey we're gonna
kidnap this little girl like and say
that it was the other cartel that did it
just to get them pissed off and like
fighting again there was a bunch of
weird [ __ ] you know that kind of like
this that happened and it happens
now it happens today but
the stuff that's been declassified that
you kind of can't talk about at least
some of it
would be like what max sogg was doing
in vietnam
and some of the [ __ ] that they were
doing was [ __ ]
pretty dirty you know
basically attacking friendlies is one of
the things that they would do
uh
to i guess to test them
or to um to punish them or
attacking a friendly that wasn't that
was actually involved with the enemy but
you couldn't let that get out you know
just stuff like they did [ __ ] like that
because there's a lot of corruption in
the south vietnamese government
you really weren't at war with laos
but they fought some of those people and
the same thing with cambodia they did
things to cambodians that they weren't
supposed to be doing
um
but that's just the nature people always
doing [ __ ] they're not supposed to yeah
yeah especially when all this war shit's
going on yeah and then money's involved
and [ __ ] people's careers are
involved these dudes have [ __ ] pools
they need to make and they need to dig
pools and they got to have
private jets private jets new wing on
the mansion and they got to get promoted
and look good in front of their bosses
and they just
most of it at that it's called echelons
above reality the higher up you go the
less those people know what's actually
happening they mostly live in a world of
lies and illusion only the grunts at the
bottom know what what's really happening
and they're telling the the chain of
command what the chain of command told
them to say
they only want to hear what they want to
hear
they'll say fix the problem but don't
tell us this and that that's not what we
want to hear we want if that happens you
get demoted but if this happens you'll
get pre-moted so everybody's lying
so
yeah
especially in places like vietnam
most of vietnam was about lying about
what the enemy kill count was and
dividing it up between the air force and
artillery units and stuff so everybody
could get promoted
and they were all we claimed to kill all
those people in vietnam it was a
fraction of that
fraction most of it was highly inflated
so you could get promoted yeah it's just
that's all it was
i think it was probably
casualties were probably pretty
comparable on both sides it's probably
50 50.
according to there was a vietnamese
general that knew the truth
and he and he said it was nowhere near
what the americans
said he gave what the real figure was i
don't remember what it was but it was a
lot less
but he knew how many were actually
killed it wasn't that many
one as many as we claimed that kind of
reminds me of when i worked for the
scientologists and they had this whole
like system where yeah uh all every job
that you did like had a point total and
your your point total was supposed to be
up every single week which is impossible
obviously yeah so um
so we would just start making numbers up
after a while because why
that's all they want to hear that's what
i'm saying here they want you to lie to
them and sure and that the arm that's
what we figure the army is like that uh
most of these uh don't trust these
government agencies hell no they're all
doing that because that's what they're
told to do it's just uh it's a scam you
know
so yeah
it's the army it was uh
a uh
would be a good way to describe it it
was a corporation of death it was
basically mcdonald's
mcdonald's of death
you know how many hamburgers are we
gonna sell well they're lying about the
amount of hamburgers they sold that kind
of [ __ ] you know what i mean but it's
the army
you know lying about how many people
that they killed
although they don't do that anymore
because that's not what they're asked to
lie about
you know vietnam they were asked they
wanted a very high kill count and then
they would say well at this rate the war
will be over in six months and that [ __ ]
drug on and on and on and on because
they were just lying
but the guys up top didn't realize
everybody was lying to him the dudes in
the middle pretty much knew but the guys
at the top didn't
because they inadvertently told
everybody to lie
yeah yeah well like i said that's what
happens if yeah if you're just basically
like well you're going to get in trouble
if you don't do xyz yeah then if you
don't do x y z you're going to tell
people you can do that exactly
exactly you know like i said same thing
that happened when i worked as a
scientologist we all figured it out
pretty quickly
so this whole thing about the united
states armed forces and [ __ ]
world-class military i was in in the 90s
when it was like one in
its best condition probably
and it still wasn't all that good it was
good but it wasn't it wasn't very it
wasn't it didn't really stress general
ship or leadership it was more
obedience and
doing what you're told and it really
really wasn't about creativity or
thinking out of the box or
it wasn't like general ship like you'd
have in world war ii that it was more
run like mcdonald's or corporations
about numbers
everything was done by numbers
and it doesn't really work well that's
easier for people to wrap their minds
around i guess yeah and general officer
core just they're not even military
really half of most of them they're just
too many too many of them and they're
soft cushy jobs where you put flunky
rich kids and they don't have military
backgrounds a lot of them and they just
stuff them away in some corner then it's
a do-nothing job and it's just free
money and there's a lot of those and
it needs to be very streamlined and all
these agencies in the government the
federal government are like that they're
like federal jobs programs they're
they're not doing anything important if
anything they're hurting everybody just
by doing stupid [ __ ]
if that all vanished
things would probably be better
because they're just confusing the
situations
um
no the government machine is just like
it doesn't really work
and at any level really local level
state level can be okay but
the bigger it is the more it sucks it's
just you can't control chaos and the
world is chaos
you just can't control anything they
want to control the world now
please smell the world oh no that didn't
work
didn't work
and that's kind of what this movie is
about it kind of shows you that
it's nice that was nice bringing it back
around bring it right down
you can't control what people do
but yeah so uh so yeah i actually really
did like this movie um it didn't get
quite as good of reviews as the first
one but it did get like pretty decent
reviews i thought it was good i thought
it was good too like i said i don't
think it was better than the first one
but it was different it doesn't mean
anything kind of interesting still good
yeah it's still like really good
i'm definitely seeing the third one oh
yeah if they do a third one i'll totally
watch it because both of these are uh
excellent so okay so let's wrap this up
because i have a whole bunch of stuff
that i'm way behind on that i really
need to get to and uh so tomorrow is our
main show
and we're gonna be doing a show about
good old john wilkes booth
the guy
that shot abraham lincoln which
everybody should know
but yeah he's kind of an interesting
dude so we're gonna do a show about him
tomorrow night
and do we have anything else that we
need to add
all right so thank you for dropping by
and hanging out with us this afternoon
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
for the main show bye